نجحت كايلا ويلر التي لم تتجاوز الس 16س
عش من عمرها في تحقيق ارقام قياسيه عالميه
رغم اصابتها بالشلل الذي قد يبقي معظم
الناس بعيدين عن
المياه وحطمت كايلا الرقم القياسي
العالميه للالعاب الاولمبيه لذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه بعد ان شاركت في
مسابقات بالمكسيك والبرازيل وهولندا ولدت
كايلا من دون رجلين وبذ واحده فقط وبدات
والدتها بتدريبها على السباحه بعد ان
نصحها الاطباء بالعلاج المائي لعبوا
السباحه مثل كايلا يتم تقسيمهم حسب مدى
عجزهم ورغم انها نجحت في التاهل
للاولمبياد الخاص في لندن عام 2012 لم
تتمكن من المشاركه بسبب نقص المتسابقين في
نفس حالتها المصنفه باس 1 وهي اكثر
الحالات عجزا التي يمكنها ممارسه
السباحه ولكن كايلا لم تستسلم فهي نشيطه
جدا
كما انها تلعب البولينج ورياضه التزلج بل
وتمارس ايضا لعبه
البيسبول وتضيف ام كايلا انها شجعتها على
عمل كل ما تريده وانتهزت ابنتها هذه
الفرصه وتقول كايلا انها تحب ان تمثل
بلدها وان تكون قدوه انها الهام للناس
داخل وخارج
المياه